Bonjour, je suis Michael Shermer, directeur de la Skeptics Society,
l'éditeur de Skeptic magazine.
Nous enquêtons sur les faits prétenduement paranormaux, les pseudo-sciences,
les groupes sectaires, et les croyances de toutes sortes qu'on peut trouver au milieu :
science, pseudo-science, non-science, science poubelle,
science vaudou, science pathologique, mauvaise science, non-science,
et absurdité pure et simple.
Et à moins que vous ayez vécu sur Mars récemment,
vous savez qu'il y a beaucoup de tout ça ici-bas.
Certains nous appellent démystificateurs, ce qui est un terme un peu péjoratif.
Mais voyons les choses en face : il y a beaucoups de mythes,
et nous sommes comme une escouade de police anti-mythes qui essaie de faire le ménage.
Nous sommes un peu les Ralph Nader des mauvaises idées,
(Rires)
on essaie de remplacer les mauvaises idées par de bonnes idées.
Je vais vous montrer un exemple de mauvaise idée.
J'ai apporté ça avec moi.
C'est l'émission NBC Dateline qui nous l'a confié pour le tester.
C'est la -- c'est fabriqué par Quadro Corporation en Virginie de l'Ouest.
Ca s'appelle la Baguette de Sourcier Quadro 2000.
(Rires)
C'était vendu 900$ l'unité à des responsables de lycée.
C'est un morceau de plastique attaché à une antenne de chez Radio Shack.
On peut chercher toutes sortes de choses avec une baguette de sourcier, mais celle-ci
a été conçue pour trouver de la marijuana dans les casiers des étudiants.
(Rires)
Voila comment ça marche, on traverse le couloir et on regarde si
ça penche devant un casier en particulier, puis on ouvre le casier en question.
Voila ce que ça donne.
Je vais vous montrer.
(Rires)
Non, il...bon, je pense qu'il penche un peu à droite.
Je vais vous montrer... c'est de la science, donc on va faire une expérience controlée.
Il ira de ce côté bien sûr.
(Rires)
Monsieur, vous voulez bien ouvrir vos poches s'il vous plait?
Donc, la question était, est-ce que ça peut vraiment détecter de la marijuana dans les casiers des étudiants?
Et la réponse est oui...si on en ouvre assez.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Mais en science, on doit tenir compte des échecs, pas seulement des succès.
Et c'est probablement la leçon clé de mon bref exposé ici,
c'est comme ça que fonctionnent les mediums, les astrologues, les tireurs de cartes, etc...
Les gens se souviennent des succès; ils oublient les fois où ça rate.
En science, nous devons conserver toutes les données,
et voir si le nombre de succès se distingue
du résultat qu'on obtiendrait par simple chance.
Pour ce cas, nous avons fait le test.
Nous avions deux boites opaques,
une contenant de la marijuana approuvée par le gouvernement, et une autre vide.
et la baguette est tombée juste une fois sur deux...
...ce qui est exactement ce qu'on obtient à pile ou face.
C'est un petit exemple marrant des choses que nous faisons.
Skeptic est une publication trimestrielle.
Chacune a un thème particulier, celle-ci traite du futur de l'intelligence.
Est-ce que les gens deviennent plus malins ou plus bêtes?
J'ai une idée sur la question à cause du milieu où je travaille.
Mais, en fait, il s'avère que les gens deviennent plus intelligents.
3 points de QI en plus tous les 10 ans.
C'est assez intéressant.
En science, ne voyez pas le scepticisme comme une chose, ni même la science comme une chose.
Est-ce que la science et la religion sont compatibles?
C'est comme demander si la science et la plomberie sont compatibles.
C'est -- ce sont juste 2 choses différentes.
La science n'est pas une chose, c'est un verbe.
C'est une façon de penser les choses.
c'est une manière de chercher des explications naturelles pour tous les phénomènes.
Par exemple, qu'est ce qui a le plus de chances d'arriver --
que des intelligences extraterrestres, ou des êtres multi-dimensionnels traversent
des distances cosmiques pour laisser un dessin
dans le champ de Bob le fermier à Puckerbrush au Kansas, pour faire la pub de notre site skeptic.com?
Ou bien est ce qu'il y a plus de chances que ce soit un lecteur de Skeptic qui ait fait ça sur Photoshop?
Et dans chaque cas, nous devons nous demander --
(Rires)
-- quelle est l'explication la plus probable?
Et avant de dire que quelque chose vient d'ailleurs,
on devrait d'abord s'assurer qu'elle ne vient pas de ce monde.
Qu'est ce qui est plus probable --
que Arnold ait reçu un petit coup de pouce extraterrestre dans sa course à la gouvernance?
Ou que le World Weekly News ait inventé cette histoire?
(Rires)
Le même thème est joliment abordé
dans ce dessin de Sidney Harris.
Pour ceux du fond, ça dit "Puis un miracle se produit."
"Je pense que vous devriez être plus explicite dans l'étape 2."
Cette simple vignette démonte complètement les arguments du "design intelligent".
Ce n'est rien de plus que ça.
(Applaudissements)
Vous pouvez dire qu'un miracle se produit.
C'est juste que ça n'explique rien.
Ca ne propose rien. Il n'y a rien à mettre à l'épreuve.
C'est la fin de la conversation pour les créationnistes du design intelligent.
Alors que -- et c'est vrai, les scientifiques utilisent parfois des
bouche-trous linguistiques comme énergie noire, ou matière noire, ou quelque chose dans le genre.
Jusqu'à ce qu'on ait trouvé ce que c'est, on l'appelera comme ça.
C'est le début de la chaine causale pour la science.
Pour les créationnistes, c'est la fin de la chaine.
Alors une fois de plus, on peut poser la question -- qu'est ce qui est le plus probable --
est-ce que les OVNI sont des vaisseaux extraterrestres, ou des erreurs de perception cognitive, ou même des canulars?
Voici un OVNI pris depuis ma maison à Altadena, en Californie,
en regardant vers Pasadena.
Et si ça ressemble à un enjoliveur de Buick, c'est parce que c'en est un.
Vous n'avez même pas besoin de Photoshop, vous n'avez pas besoin d'équipement de pointe,
vous n'avez pas besoin d'ordinateurs.
Cette photo a été prise avec un appareil jetable Kodak Instamatic.
Il suffit d'avoir quelqu'un hors champ prêt à lancer l'enjoliveur.
L'appareil photo est prêt -- c'est dans la boîte.
(Rires)
Donc, bien qu'il soit possible que la plupart des OVNI soient des faux
ou des illusions, ou autre, et que certains d'entre eux soient réels,
il est plus probable qu'ils soient tous des faux, comme les motifs dans les champs.
Pour parler plus sérieusement, en science on cherche toujours l'équilibre
entre données et théorie.
Dans le cas de Galilée, il avait 2 problèmes
quand il tourna son téléscope vers Saturne.
Pour commencer, il n'y avait pas de théorie des anneaux planétaires.
Ensuite, ses données étaient granuleuses et floues,
et il ne savait pas vraiment ce qu'il était en train de regarder.
Alors il écrivit qu'il avait vu --
"J'ai observé que la planète la plus éloignée a 3 corps."
Et c'est ce qu'il conclut qu'il avait vu.
Donc, sans une théorie des anneaux planétaires, et seulement des données granuleuses,
vous ne pouvez pas avoir une bonne théorie.
Et ce ne fut pas résolu avant 1655.
C'est le livre de Christiaan Huygens, dans lequel il catalogua toutes les erreurs
que les gens avaient faites en essayant de comprendre ce qui se passait avec Saturne.
Ce ne fut pas avant -- Huygens avait deux choses.
Il avait une bonne théorie des anneaux planétaires et de la façon dont le système solaire fonctionnait.
Ensuite, son téléscope obtenait des données plus fines,
grâce auxquelles il put comprendre que comme la Terre va plus vite --
selon les lois de Kepler -- que Saturne, nous finissons par la rattraper.
Et nous voyons les anneaux sous des angles différents, comme ici.
Et ceci est effectivement vrai.
Le problème quand on a une théorie
c'est qu'elle peut être faussée par des erreurs cognitives
Donc un des problèmes relatifs à l'explication des croyances étranges
c'est que nous avons des tendances, d'abord simples.
Et j'en donnerais de plus sérieuses ensuite.
Par exemple, nous avons tendance à voir des visages.
C'est le visage de Mars, qui fut --
en 1976, il y eut tout un mouvement pour que la NASA
prenne des photos de cette zone parce que les gens pensaient
qu'il s'agissait d'une architecture monumentale conçue par les Martiens.
Et il s'avère que -- voici le gros plan qui date de 2001.
Si vous plissez les yeux, vous pouvez encore voir le visage.
Et quand vous plissez, vous faites passer
cette image d'un grain fin à un grain épais.
Et par conséquent, vous réduisez la qualité de vos données.
Et si je ne vous avais pas dit ce qu'il fallait regarder, vous verriez toujours le visage,
parce que nous sommes programmés par l'évolution pour voir des visages.
Socialement, les visages sont importants pour nous.
Et, bien sur, les visages heureux.
Des visages de toutes sortes sont faciles à voir.
(Rires)
Vous pouvez voir le visage heureux de Mars, ici.
Si les astronomes étaient des grenouilles, peut-être qu'ils verraient Kermit la Grenouille.
Vous le voyez?
avec ses petites cuisses de grenouilles.
Ou si les géologues étaient des éléphants?
Iconographie religeuse.
(Rires)
Découvert par un boulanger du Tennessee en 1996.
Il faisait payer 5$ par personne pour venir voir le petit pain en forme de nonne
jusqu'a ce que l'avocat de Mère Teresa le somme d'arrêter.
Ici nous avons Notre Dame De Guadalupe et Notre Dame de Watsonville, qui se trouve juste en bas de la rue.
Ou est-ce que c'est en haut de la rue à partir d'ici?
L'écorce d'arbre est particulèrement efficace à cause de sa jolie texture granuleuse,
ses taches noires et blanches, et vous pouvez distinguer le motif --
les humains sont des animaux traqueurs de motifs.
Voici la Vierge Marie au bord d'une vitre à Sao Paulo.
Et ici, la Vierge Marie qui apparait sur un sandwich au fromage --
que j'ai d'ailleurs tenu dans mes mains dans un casino de Las Vegas,
bien sûr, on est en Amérique.
(Rires)
Ce casino a dépensé 28500$ sur eBay pour acheter ce sandwich.
Mais est-ce que ça ressemble vraiment à la Vierge Marie?
(Rires)
Les lèvres font plutôt pin-up des années 40.
Vierge Marie à Clearwater, en Floride.
Je suis allé voir celle-ci.
Il y avait beaucoup de monde -- les fidèles venaient avec leurs --
fauteuils roulants, leur béquilles, etc.
Et nous sommes allés enquêter.
Pour vous donner une idée de la taille -- c'est Dawkins, moi et L'Incroyable Randi,
a côté de cette image de deux étages et demi.
Toutes ces bougies, des milliers de bougies que les gens avaient allumé en signe de ferveur.
On est allé faire un tour derrière le batiment, histoire de voir ce qui se passait,
Et il s'avère que partout où il y a un arroseur automatique et un palmier,
vous obtenez l'effet.
Ici la Vierge Marie de derrière, qu'ils avaient commencé à nettoyer.
J'imagine qu'on a droit qu'à un miracle par building.
(Rires)
Alors est-ce que c'est vraiment un miracle de Marie, ou un miracle de Marge?
Et je conclurai avec un autre exemple du genre
avec les illusions auditives.
Il y a un film avec Michael Keaton, "La Voix des Morts",
dans lequel les morts nous répondent.
Au passage, tout ce cirque de communication avec les morts, c'est pas sorcier.
N'importe qui peut le faire en fait.
C'est quand il s'agit d'obtenir une réponse que ça se corse.
(Rires)
Dans ce cas, les messages sont censés être cachés dans des phénomènes éléctroniques.
Il y a une page du site ReverseSpeech.com sur laquelle j'ai téléchargé ça.
C'est le plus connu des trucs de ce genre.
Voici la version normale de la célèbre chanson.
On pouvait écouter ça toute la journée pas vrai?
(Rires)
Ok, voici la version à l'envers,
voyez si vous pouvez entendre les messages cachés qui sont supposés être là-dedans.
Vous avez compris quoi?
(Le public: Satan)
Michael Shermer: Satan? Ok, nous avons au moins Satan.
Maintenant, je vais conditionner la partie auditive de votre cerveau
en vous disant ce que vous êtes censés entendre, et donc, écoutez à nouveau.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
Vous ne pouvez pas le rater quand je vous dis ce qu'il y a à entendre.
(Rires)
Bien, je vais finir avec une jolie petite histoire positive
les Skeptics sont une organisation éducative à but non lucratif.
On est toujours à la recherche de petits trucs biens que les gens font.
Et en Angleterre, il y a une chanteuse pop.
Une des plus célèbres en Angleterre aujourd'hui, Katie Melua.
Et elle a écrit une chanson superbe.
Elle était dans le top 5 en 2005, ça s'appelait "9 millions de bicyclettes à Pékin."
C'est une histoire d'amour -- elle est un peu la Norah Jones anglaise --
qui raconte à quel point elle aime son mec,
et elle compare ça à 9 millions de bicyclettes, etc.
Et il y a ce passage.